temptation sunday's kicks off pride
month with a splash this sunday at the
luxor hotel and casino and here to tell
us all about las vegas longest running
lgbtq plus pool party is james healy
with the mgm resorts and eduardo cordova
the temptation sundays hosts how you
guys doing doing great jc good to see
you great to see you again great to have
you here tell me more about the pool
party that's going down this weekend
well this is we're really excited to
kick off pride month um this weekend
with miss nevada cataluna enriquez yes
she's beautiful and amazing and we have
so many surprises uh for for this sunday
and we're so happy because we're
celebrating 12 years
this this year which is amazing longest
running here in town now there's a check
presentation happening as well on sunday
tell us more about this yeah so mgm
resorts has been a part of the lgbt
community and really the founder in the
city since 2003 and again as eduardo
mentioned this is the 12th year that
we've hosted temptation sundays at luxor
and we're really excited this year to
partner with eduardo uh and really take
it to the next level as this becomes a
destination for las vegas and in the
community and not just lgbtq community
it's everybody it's a huge part it's a
huge party now i mean we've got a
thousand people out there on a sunday
wow but it's so exciting
mgm resorts has been commuted to the
lgbtq community and this event really
put us on the map we've been a part of
the community since 2003 as we were the
very first
promoter and sponsor of las vegas pride
2004 we were the first gaming company to
offer same-sex at that time we didn't
have marriage for equality so same-sex
benefits and we've just continued in
fact this year uh hrc has named mgm
resorts the best place to work uh for
equality and that's based on the 11th
year in a row that we've rescored 100 on
the corporate equality index so this
event is just a way to tie it all
together and it's pride month yes
exactly it's a great time to celebrate
so let's get some more of the details of
the part you said a thousand people are
gonna be out there we have a dj on
sunday yes we've been breaking record
attendance just past you know month on
on just the party every sunday starts at
noon it goes all the way to six uh we
have amazing dracon host uh you know we
have surprises coming up on this sunday
we um
the luxury's giving out swag for
everybody we're amongst friends here
yeah you gotta drop me a little
breadcrumb what's one of the surprises
you gotta give me something give me a
little something mgm is going to
be presenting three organizations some
pretty sizable contributions and then
we'll do those check presentations to
those three organizations those are
lgbtq local organizations that will
benefit from mgm resorts it's something
we're really proud to be able to get
back into the community and particularly
this community which is so important to
us now people are watching right now
they want to go they want to attend can
we make reservations do you buy tickets
to go how does it work getting in you
can go to
temptationsundaysnlv.com make a
reservation um tickets for locals or
twenty dollars for tourists or thirty
dollars and you can also get our free
guest list from twelve to nine two
twelve to one and before we started we
saw what the weather's gonna be great on
sunday 101 that's perfect
thank you so much for joining us today
we appreciate it yes
yeah absolutely
absolutely happy pride month thank you
so much rocky we'll send it over to you
all right temptation sundays
sounds like